new album
well by the time this is uh Out the
album will be out yep yes make sure you
go listen give it a listen man go buy it
on iTunes big features you got Polo G
Italy Choppa a baby face Ray obviously
gun is on the album we've heard that
song for a while I'm forgetting somebody
else
um Kevin Gates who you were on tour with
yeah
what was that like it was fun man he's a
great guy I feel like he's a little
misunderstood yeah yeah he cool dude
he's in great shape too man yeah I need
to work out every day I saw him with
that wheel today on oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
was it was like he's also known as like
one of the best performers
do you feel like you've learned anything
from them
watching him yeah it was it was just
really like
I would say inspiring just to see
all them people probably know because I
wasn't even promoting the tour to be
honest like I wasn't like posting about
it or nothing like that right like I was
just on the shows but them [ __ ]
was packed packed out one might say why
would you even agree to do the tour if
you didn't plan on promoting it it
wasn't a plan on promoting it it's just
I just wasn't you know so I just wasn't
actively promoting because I'm like this
[ __ ] is already sold out it's an
already sold out too yeah what the [ __ ]
I'm gonna promote I'm standing outside
that [ __ ] you know I'm standing outside
and listen to my [ __ ] from from the
street it didn't make no sense so I was
just like the whole tour was sold out
yeah for the most part that's big man he
was doing like random ass [ __ ] like we
was at the bottom of Mississippi and
[ __ ] random ass cities where was like uh
any any like weird situations you found
yourself in being in any of those random
cities
um
nah not really it was just I don't know
people just different everywhere yeah
but it was you know it was cool on the
bus was this your first like super big
big tour yeah that was my first time
like going on tour with somebody yeah
like I usually just do my own tour right
was it uh obviously bigger venues than
you used to yeah hell yeah for sure he
was doing amphitheaters yeah he was
doing some big things some of them was
Arenas though Arena I'm stop saying it's
crazy man nah that [ __ ] was lit can you
try to convert you to Muslim nah no no
no no I feel like I feel like a lot of
people hang out with Kevin Gates and
then I interview him after and they're a
Muslims
and that ain't happening you did he
didn't try he didn't have a little combo
about it nah yeah [ __ ] hella spiritual
though he you know he'd be saying [ __ ]
like you know what's the most hella
spiritual thing he said to you that you
kept with you
um I don't remember it was a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] it was a lot of [ __ ] yeah
cool though man